lo que haremos en este vídeo será hablar
de acidez pero en particular hablaremos
de la escala de ph y la primera pregunta
es qué significa ph bueno resulta que
hay un poco de debate sobre por qué se
escribe esta p en minúscula si sabemos
por qué tenemos la h
pero algunas personas apoyan la idea de
que p h significa poder de hidrógeno la
h mayúscula es por hidrógeno pero otras
personas dicen que es por potencial de
hidrógeno podemos ver que se origina de
latín con dos potencias pero no nos
enfoquemos en eso preguntémonos qué es
lo que esto significa y por qué nos
preocupamos tanto por el hidrógeno bueno
esto es porque el hidrógeno y en
particular el ión positivo del hidrógeno
con ión me refiero a la molécula en este
caso cargada positivamente unión de
hidrógeno puede jugar un papel muy
importante en la determinación de que
tan ácido o tan
es algo vamos a ver una escala de ph va
desde 0 hasta 14 y claro el 7 se
encuentra justo a la mitad entonces
miren cuando algo se encuentra hacia la
izquierda es decir si algo tiene un
valor de ph menor a 7 se considera ácido
y por ejemplo si algo tiene un ph
cercano a 0 eso significa que es muy
ácido mientras que hacia la derecha se
considera que es básico y si tenemos
algo justo a la mitad se dice que es
neutro otro término que se utiliza para
decir que algo es básico es alcalino que
proviene de la palabra árabe al cali que
es la que usaban los científicos árabes
antiguos para llamar a un compuesto que
era muy básico de acuerdo a nuestra
definición moderna pero que significa
que algo sea ácido y que algo sea básico
como se conecta eso con los iones de
hidrógeno bueno no voy a profundizar
mucho sobre eso
en este vídeo pero podemos decir que las
cosas que son ácidas tienen muchos iones
de hidrógeno mientras que las cosas que
son básicas tienden a reaccionar
reaccionan con esos iones de hidrógeno y
existen otras definiciones para explicar
qué es un ácido y una base pero todo eso
lo pueden ver en una clase de química
aquí solamente quería explicarles por
qué todo esto se conecta con el término
de ph entonces qué ejemplos podríamos
dar de cosas que son ácidas
bueno aquí tenemos un diagrama donde
ahora la escala de ph se encuentra en
posición vertical y podemos encontrar
muchas cosas en nuestra vida diaria que
son ácidas por ejemplo muchas frutas
como los limones las toronjas y las
naranjas son bastante ácidas se
encuentran hasta el fondo de la escala y
uno de los signos indicativos de acidez
es cuando algo que comemos o bebemos
tiene un sabor agrio pero si analizamos
el otro lado del
pero en las cosas básicas tenemos
algunos ejemplos como blanqueadores
solución de amoniaco y podemos encontrar
algo todavía más básico como los
limpiadores líquidos de drenaje y todos
estos ejemplos tienen una textura
similar y resbaladiza incluso el jabón
es bastante básico bueno respecto a
todas las cosas básicas que podemos
comer podemos decir que son aquellas que
tienen un sabor amargo pero para ser
claros no les recomiendo que coman o
beban algo que sea muy básico o muy
ácido porque las cosas que se encuentran
en alguno de los dos extremos de la
escala de ph es decir aquellas cosas que
son extremadamente básicas o
extremadamente ácidas como el ácido de
las bacterias o el ácido clorhídrico al
ser muy reactivos pueden hacernos daño
si los tocamos nos pueden lastimar o si
los ingerimos pueden dañar nuestras
células e incluso matarnos no intenten
tomar cosas que sepan que son muy ácidas
o básicas mejor asegúrense de que se
encuentren dentro del rango intermedio
de la escala de ph y bueno ya hablamos
mucho de cosas que son ácidas o básicas
pero también es muy interesante todo
aquello que se considera neutro por
ejemplo nuestra sangre es neutra y esto
es algo que los doctores revisan porque
si el ph de nuestra sangre es un poco
más alto o bajo puede causarnos serios
problemas por otra parte el agua de mar
se encuentra cerca de ser neutra al
igual que la leche que no está muy lejos
con eso dicho para poder leer la escala
de ph correctamente o apreciar las
diferencias de acidez o basij cidad es
importante darse cuenta de que esta es
una escala lineal por ejemplo si algo
tiene un ph de 8 no significa que sea el
doble de básico de algo que tiene un ph
de 4 más bien cuando pasamos de un ph de
phd 5 incrementamos la base cidad por un
factor de 10 entonces al comparar con
algo que tiene un ph de 4 a un ph de 8
aquello que tiene un ph de 4 sería 10
100 mil 10.000 veces más ácido o
podríamos decir que aquello que tiene un
ph de 8 es 10 100 mil 10 mil veces más
básico pero vamos a dejarlo aquí ahora
ya saben un poco de qué hablamos cuando
mencionamos el ph de la sangre por
ejemplo conforme estudiamos más y más
biología hablaremos sobre como el ph
puede influenciar en algunas reacciones
biológicas y sobre todo una vez que nos
adentremos en la química el ph nos dirá
qué tipo de reacción puede ocurrir hemos
terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo